I'm having a great day I've been in LA
about four and a half years and when you
moved to LA you guys start being
healthier and then that time I'm very
proud to say this I've lost a total of
55 pounds that's right Matt okay you
guys are slow to clap like you're still
kind of fat
I've got a clap for a half-ass cheat
I just made some change to stop drinking
soda working out and I lost like 15
pounds and like the first month and a
half and my doctor was like hey you need
lose weight at like a slower pace I
didn't know that there's a medical
condition that goes to losing too much
weight too quickly it's called extra
skin and it sucks it's not a sucks as
you can't do anything with it except
maybe make someone feel better if
they're having like a bad day case in
point I saw this little kid they're like
are you having a bad day little buddy's
like oh my god I can make it all better
you want to see a puppy a shar-pei I
also don't like that fat people get
treated in this country man we get
nickels and dime if you're overweight in
America if you want a bigger seat on a
plane they're gonna charge you more
money if you want a bigger shirt they're
gonna charge you more money there needs
to be like a civil rights movement for
fat people and I know one thing we're
not going to March
just could be a lot of sit-ins one of
the real reasons why I have a shop
losing weight was about five and a half
years ago I suffered an ascending aortic
aneurysm for those that don't know about
that you can have an aneurysm in one of
three places your head your chest and
your stomach I had mine in my chest the
doctor gave me a nice 140 thousand
dollar chest tattoo him I'll show it to
you now because I'm still paying for it
and I'd have insurance when I had that
surgery that's the one question people
like to ask is how'd you pay for it
basically what I had to do is I worked
out a deal with the hospital I pay them
$20 a month until the year 2000 kiss my
ass you should have killed me when you
had the chance
they sent me a bill for a hundred and
thirty-eight thousand two hundred and
twenty one dollars and 37 cents they
listed the cents on that bill like I was
in my room right in the checkout like
hey what's the cents on that they're
gonna get all of it
you ever get a bill so big it just turns
into a Batman villain just I was in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania when I actually
okay my memories are different
it was it was a Saturday before his show
that I had I was in a rush to get back
to the hotel to get ready for the show
I'm already go through drive-thru I eat
midway through getting dressed I started
having the worst chest pain I've ever
felt and at first I was like relax
that's just the McDonald's that's how
you know it's working I freaked out I
called my won-won they said sir stay
calm we'll have someone there in just a
few minutes the most important thing you
can do right now is stay calm I get four
minutes of his bond I get I open the
door it's a cop I'll never forget what
he said to me because you're too young
to be having heart trouble what kind of
drugs have you been doing I have a Big
Mac you need to help me I get to the ER
85% of the people that have what I had
died within the first 15 minutes I made
it a little over two hours I'm wearing I
checked in my era room I didn't see a
nurse for a good little bit and she
comes in kind of briskly doesn't even
look at me and say hello Sheila to my
chart first just sweetie do you want to
talk to a priest I really wanted to talk
to a doctor first surgeon comes in I'll
never forget his last name dr. Montez he
told me I had to have emergency six-hour
surgery and based on the size of my
dissection of my chest I had about a 15%
chance to live I don't want to spoil the
rest of this story
but I lived thank you very much guys
look at this my face
[Applause]
you